i watch perfect blue recently I'm proud
of you I'm proud of you unlike gone
right where if we bring up or share your
light yeah you should watch it God's
gonna be like I actually started
watching daughter head or you actually
gonna know that because that was on the
episode where we recorded an episode and
then the audio just wasn't recording
apparently lost episode you'll get to
see it like a ten minute speech on white
daughter her daughter was good and you
should watch it yeah but oh yeah blue
yeah yeah how did you find it it was
amazing like I okay I knew it's gonna be
good right everything I've seen of it
and then the amount of works that its
inspires obviously is gonna be good yeah
yeah but yeah I was kind of not ready no
one is on they watch it like yeah yeah
so the scenes are pretty yeah like how
do you feel watching it today like
because this came out and I think 1995
saw me or something like that which
1995-1997 you came out in the least
twenty years old yeah how would you feel
it hat is now watching for the first
time in today's climate it's really
creepy being like an online personality
watching a story at Brian yeah in
personality and that's what's scary
about it right is that the themes in
that are just as prevalent today as I
was back then yeah it's not worse I know
no I I feel like it's more relevant
today over 20 years later oh yeah than
it was when it came out you want to
explain quickly what the story is cuz
like it's been awhile since I watched ah
it's it's a mindfuck it's it's horror
but it's essentially there's this girl
who is an idol she then quits becoming
an idol to pursue a career in film
acting but then that's also like a sign
but yes a guy who is obsessed with her
and the whole point of the story is that
he is obsessed with the image of the
celebrity not the actual personality of
the celebrity yeah and then it's kind of
a story about how much as an online
personality or a fan or celebrity how
much of your public persona do you own
and how much of that do you have control
over yeah is it is it actually you who
is the real use is it who you perceive
yourself as online or is it who you are
as a person and the fact that this came
out in the 90s where
way ahead of its time like what the [ __ ]
right it predicted so much about how
social media would work in our
perceptions of like online celebrities
and how people are viewed online and
just like Satoshi Kon it's like
cinematography is just yes so out of
this well I love that scene the one
scene I vividly remember is like when
the stalker guy is at like the main
characters like concert yeah and he just
holds his hand up yeah yeah that is just
so so because it's just such good
imagery yeah he was ugly as [ __ ] oh you
look like a human beetle I was like oh
so he's the bad boy was the og yeah
every ugly boss was based on Oh kid it
was amazing like it was if I feel like
it's again like you said it's irrelevant
this time I think yeah anyone King do I
think it's more relevant now than it was
almost when it came out and the way the
way he pulled it off as well I was it
wasn't just a simple story
it was weaved in with just pure
top-class filmmaking like like there was
there's a point when you don't notice
the transition but it transitions into
okay what's real what's lining her
imagination what's what's part of the
film because one of the genius parts of
this story is that because she's like an
actress as well as the world of the
acting yeah they they use the word of
the acting and like the filmmaking to
like blend into her real life so you
don't know which scenes are like freely
happening and which scenes are just
being acted and it's it [ __ ] with your
mind exercise right because yes the the
real world the acting world and then the
stiff that she's seeing and I had yeah
it's so hard trying to like unwind all
that now yeah I figure out what's what
but then I guess almost a certain extent
you know supposed to yeah yeah confused
yeah the fact that you're so worried is
what's like showing you why this whole
thing is so scary yeah you don't even
know watching yeah what is real and what
is not real right yeah and I feel a lot
of that kind of like theming in Satoshi
Khan's movies really transition over to
his later stuff like did you ever watch
paprika oh yeah I did I do
paprika I mean for those of you don't
know it's literally my phantom a
inception I mean it's totally different
because it's like Inception is like a
heist movie
be in a dream Satoshi it's like paprika
is like on a on a base level yeah
they're both about dreams but for pre-k
is like 10 times more imaginative in
like how he approaches its visuals when
when in like they're in the dream world
right and that and how he shows the
dream world versus the real world is
very much like imperfect blue where you
don't realize oh we're in a dream world
now
oh we're back to reality and it's he
does that so seamlessly through his
scenes it's really incredible yeah I
think perfectly is my favorite Toshi
Khan movie close second is millennium
actually max I love people who said
though his best work yeah because I
think he took a lot of elements from
perfect blue in terms of like so
millennium actress isn't a mindfuck but
it basically tells the story of this
girl through film basically so kind they
I think she was young she the names
millennium actress you see she's an
actor I was like was she an actress on
the Millenium farmer she was a farm